Good morning again, church.
My name's John, one of the pastors here.
Uh, if you're new to our church,
we're grateful you'd be here.
We'd love to meet you.
Uh, if you've been here for a long time.
We also are glad you're here
and we love that we get to do this together.
Uh, so go ahead and take your copy of God's Word.
Turn with me to First Samuel. We're going through this book.
We'll be in chapter eight today.
First Samuel, chapter eight.
Now, you may have noticed that I have a loop
of climbing rope up here.
We thought of having me repel down from the ceiling,
but that might be a bit too much.
So, uh, this is what we're gonna do with this.
It's just something that is an illustration of
what I heard a pastor talk about one time, the difference
between repelling and climbing.
Uh, that there is a difference.
Maybe you don't understand that, but let me explain it.
When you repel, you start at the top of a rock face
and you kind of lean back onto the rope.
And to get down, you have
to put your whole weight on the rope as you kind of hop
or walk down the rock face.
But when you rock climb, you are finding footholds
and handholds to climb up the rock, rock face.
And the rope is there merely if you fall off, if you
misstep and you are
secure in case you fall.
There's other people who actually climb with no ropes, but,
but that's who most people, as most people would do,
is they climb with a rope as a safety net.
Have you ever considered that?
Maybe that's what you are doing in your
relationship with God.
Do you merely want God as your safety net
as your rope if you fall,
but primarily you're trusting in your own strength
and you climb in life?
Do you not fully trust him
like you would when you repel down the face?
We're actually gonna see an example of that
today in one Samuel.
As we continue our journey through this book.
We're we're coming today to a pivotal section
regarding the shift to a monarchy
that's been building throughout one Samuel.
Now there's this, the distinct moment where this happens.
In reality though, there's a deeper question.
It's not just structural government type stuff.
We're gonna see a civics lesson.
The deeper question that is asked here is, who shall reign?
Who shall reign?
Who will sit on the throne of the people's hearts,
who will sit on the throne of their nation?
Yes, but who's gonna sit on the throne of their hearts?
Who's gonna be the one to protect them
and prosper them and fulfill them?
Who's gonna be the one that trust to do that?
And we're faced with similar questions today, right?
Who's gonna sit on the throne of our hearts?
Who will we trust to bring us prosperity
and security and fulfillment?
Those are essential questions that we'll see today.
Look now at chapter eight verses one through nine.
When Samuel became old, he made his sons judges over Israel.
The name of his firstborn son was Joel, the name
of his second Aja.
There were judges in Beersheba,
which is a very south part of the nation.
Yet his sons did not walk in his ways, but turned aside
after gain and they took bribes
and perverted justice sounds familiar to what we saw, right?
With Eli and his sons.
Then all the elders of Israel gathered together came
to Samuel at Rama and said to him, behold, you are old
and your sons do not walk in your ways.
Now appoint for us a king to judge us like all the nations.
But the thing displeased Samuel, when they said,
give us a king to judge us.
And Samuel prayed to the Lord,
and the Lord said to Samuel, obey the voice
of the people in all that they say to you,
for they have not rejected you,
but they have rejected me from being king over them
according to all the deeds
that they've done from the day I brought them up out
of Egypt, even to this day forsaking me
and serving other gods.
So they're also doing to you now then obey their voice.
Only you shall solemnly warn them
and show them the ways of the king
who shall reign over them.
So a lot of time has passed since we saw Samuel
as a young boy left in the tabernacle to serve the Lord.
And, and it's a long time has passed as he's been called
to ministry, he's actually been serving publicly.
But what Samuel did here, we, we learned, is
that he was actually perpetuating the same system
of government that they had had prior.
In fact, he was doing it in a way that was kind
of creating this lineage in a, in a sense, perpetuating
what would turn into being the monarchy.
Like he was opening the door wide open to it,
appointing his sons as judges.
Like that's just what they did.
And so the door swings open, the people asked.
But like I've said this
before, none of these things surprised God.
In fact, in all the way back in Deuteronomy 17, verse 20,
God had told Israel he would give them a king one day.
So God knew this was coming.
It was the way that they asked here
that would displease God.
Did you see it? Right? Verse eight, God said,
Israel had forsaken him.
They'd served these other gods.
In fact, in verse seven, we put this
as the main point on your notes.
God said it this way.
They have rejected me from being king over them,
right God, God said that.
Listen again, they have rejected me
from being king over them.
Just think about that for a second.
God already was their king.
He was the one who had protect them, prosper them,
fulfill them, but they
rejected him as that a word
that brings with it the idea of contempt.
You could almost read this like they spit in his face
whenever they said, no, we don't want you as our king,
we want another king.
They got impatient, right?
I mean, 'cause just think about their situation.
They had physical needs that they had to have met.
They had these enemies that were lurking all
around them all the time
and they thought they needed someone more tangible,
more reliable than an invisible God.
They weren't really sure where he was,
but they need somebody they can see
who can lead them into battle, which is a rejection
of the very thing
that made them distinct from all the nations around them.
How silly they were, right?
Like we, we would, we would never do that,
as Dwight would say, false, right?
We do this all the time.
Here's one way. We need
to see a couple extra zeros at the end
of our bank account just to make sure we're secure.
Maybe this one, here's, here's
how we can place our hope outside of God.
We can, we can hope in something other than God.
Every day on the news, every day on your Facebook feed
claims, this is the most consequential election in history.
They said it four years ago,
they said it four years ago before that.
They'll say it in four years from now, everyone.
And what it does is it stirs up fear.
It stirs up this panic,
and we're placing our hope in something outside of God.
And listen, I even as I say that,
we live in a democratic republic,
so we have the privilege to get to vote.
So pray, vote your conscience. Yes, absolutely do that.
But let's stop acting as if a certain candidate gets elected
or a certain candidate doesn't get elected,
then the whole world will spin out of control, right?
Because is God not sovereign over this thing?
Does he not have a plan? Is he not good?
Here's my point. Whether it's a politician or a job
or a spouse or a bank account
or whatever it is, we forsake God.
When we trust any other king,
we forsake God.
Now notice this is in quotes, the king word, right?
We forsake God when we trust any other king.
'cause here's the truth, God is the king.
He is the king of kings and the Lord of lords.
In fact, I love the way Psalm 47 puts it. Clap your hands.
All peoples shout to God with loud songs of joy
for the Lord, Yahweh, the most high is to be feared.
A great king over all the earth. Amen. Sing praises to God.
Sing praises to our king. Sing praises.
For God is the king of all the earth.
Sing praises with a psalm. God reigns over the nations.
God sits on his holy throne.
So hear me this, we cannot knock him off his throne.
He absolutely is always will be. That's his rightful place.
But here's what we can do just like Israel did.
We can forsake him with contempt.
We can act as if we're the king of our own lives.
We've got a chair.
Listen, I heard a one of our staff members told me this,
that their child wrote this simple one sentence story
and it was a b, a boy named Bob who had a chair
and he liked to play king with it.
Is that not what we see happen every
single day in our own hearts.
We have a chair and we like to play king with it.
We think we're the king of our own lives.
We act as if this or that will give us protection
or provision or fulfillment.
That that's what's gonna be our hope.
That's what's going to be sufficient and suffice for us.
That's what we mean by king here.
You can't take God off his throne.
But anything we look to for provision, protection,
fulfillment, anything, we seek to find it.
Which the Bible also identifies as idolatry.
It doesn't have to be figurines and things on shelves.
It can be what you look for.
What I look for for purpose and provision and fulfillment.
That's the king we're talking about.
And only God was meant to carry the weight
of kingship in our lives.
Nothing else. It's all shifting, crumbling foundations.
Only God can be the true king and carry that.
Now back to the story. Did you see
what God told Samuel in verse nine?
Samuel's like, Hey God, they asked for a king.
God's like, okay, give 'em a king,
but you shall solemnly warn them
and show them the ways
of the king who shall reign over them.
Be careful what you ask for, right?
'cause look how Samuel then spoke to the people.
Look at verses 10 through 18 and kids listen for something.
I want to, I'm gonna emphasize a word.
So kids try to check, check in.
Listen to what I say,
what I emphasize here, verses 10 through 18.
So Samuel told all the words of the Lord to the people
who are asking for a king from him.
He said, these will be the ways of the king
who shall reign over you.
He will take your sons and appoint them to his chariots
and to be his horsemen and to run before his chariots.
And he will appoint for himself commanders of thousands,
of commanders of fifties and sum to plow his ground,
to reap his harvest, to make his implements of war
and the equipment of his chariots.
He will take your daughters to be perfumers
and cooks and bakers.
He will take the best of your fields and vineyards
and olive orchards and give them to his servants.
He will take the 10th of your grain of your vineyards,
give it to his officers and his servants.
He will take your male servants
and female servants in the best of your young men
and your donkeys and put them to his work.
He will take the 10th of your flocks
and you shall be his slaves.
And in that day, you'll cry out
because of your king whom you've chosen for yourselves.
But the Lord will not answer you in that day.
Did you catch it? Here's why I
emphasize that
because what God was telling the people there is
that any other king will only take,
he will not give
any king that we set up
will take from us, not give to us.
Now, what Samuel was describing was the common practice
of kings back then at his time.
It's how worldly kings functioned back then.
It makes total sense, right?
They, they needed young men in their army
to defend the nation.
And so they would conscript these young men,
they would assign some to work in his fields
'cause he had a lot of fields to provide
for all the things he needed to work in his palace to
to do work in the manufacturing, all of that.
He would snatch the fields of people to provide
for his people that he had working for him.
And in the end, what it led to was enslaving the people.
Which is why verse 18 in that day, you will cry out
because of your king whom you've chosen for yourselves.
In other words, God was saying, Hey,
I'm warning you this will not go well.
If you do it the way you want to, it's not going
to end well.
In fact, I love this two Chronicles 12, eight.
In the new living translation, God says they,
Israel will become the king's subjects slaves.
So they will know the difference between serving me
and serving earthly rulers.
Like we have a choice. Who are we gonna serve?
See? But, but again, like I said it, it wasn't the request
for a king that was necessarily wrong
'cause God said it was going to come.
It was the way they went about it that as they asked
for this worldly king, they also in the same breath
rejected God.
That's why God said to them, okay, okay, I'll, I'll give you
what you want, but here's what's gonna come of it.
This is what's going to happen when you do it the world's
way because do you remember
why Israel would, would be willing to submit
to this worldly king?
Why would they even do this?
Remember it was because they felt this lack of security.
They felt this lack of prosperity.
They looked around and they saw
that a worldly king would be better.
We need somebody to lead us into battle
like everybody else around us.
We need to, we have this felt need here.
We need to do something that would fix it.
But remember what it ended up doing?
Taking and taking and taking some more from them.
But again, we can't sit here a couple thousand years later
and look back and say, you guys have no clue
because don't we do the same thing?
Don't we get ourselves in the same situation they did.
We feel a lack in our lives.
And so we turn to something else to fix it.
We turn to a king that can never satisfy,
that was never intended to satisfy,
but instead of giving what we need, it only takes from us.
You heard it at the beginning of the service today.
And we turn to things like pornography to try
to satisfy the lust of our flesh.
And what it ends up doing is it destroys
and rots away our minds.
It only takes from us, it takes families away,
or you sacrifice yourself to climb that corporate ladder.
But what it ends up doing is it destroys your family.
It only takes from you or you set up
a relationship as the fulfillment that you know you need.
But what it ends up doing is it steals your joy when
that person inevitably lets you down
and you've looked to to have it give you something
and instead takes away something from it.
Listen, if we present ourselves to
any other king, it's not going to save us.
In fact, it's only going to tyrannize us.
It will only take, it will only take. It will only take.
It will not give you what it promises, it will give you.
It will not make you happy. It will only steal your joy.
It will steal your peace.
And Jesus said it very simply,
familiar verse John 10 10, the thief comes only
to steal and kill and destroy.
But Jesus says, I came that they may have life
and have it abundantly.
So why do we do it? Why?
Why do we walk down roads that lead to stealing
and death destruction?
Why do we turn to these other kings in our lives?
Well watch why we see Israel here.
Chapter eight, verse Samuel eight verses 19 through 22.
Remember he had just warned them,
this is what's gonna happen if you ask
for a king like everybody else.
This is what's gonna happen. He warned them. Watch verse 19.
But the people refuse to obey the voice of Samuel.
And they said, no,
but there should be a king over us
that we may also be like all the nations,
that our king may judge us and go out before us
and fight our battles.
When Samuel had heard all the words of the people,
he repeated them in the ears of the Lord.
And the Lord said to Samuel, obey their voice.
Make them a king. Samuel then said to the men of Israel,
go every man to his city.
You see what happened there?
The point is, trouble comes when we start comparing.
Trouble comes when we start comparing.
Listen again to verse 20, their reasoning.
So that we also may be like all the nations
and that our king may judge us and go out before us
and fight our battles.
That was their reason. Now just stop
for a second and think about where we've come.
That's why we don't read this in a vacuum, right?
We've walked from chapter one all the way through.
Now we, we've watched this happen.
Did they forget what had just
happened in chapters five through seven?
Like did they, did they completely lose the thought?
I know it'd been a few years, but do
you remember what God did?
Do you remember on his own
what God did in the whole process?
Like the Ark of the Covenant going
and God himself by himself invaded Felicia.
He executed their God DayOne, he distributed plagues
to the people and then he brought home all the plunder.
And then not only that, he destroyed the Philistine army
with thunder and a spirit of confusion.
He did that all by himself.
And the Israelites were watching all of that happen.
No, we still need a king.
They could even look back to Exodus.
Remember Exodus, God himself plagues in all the people.
Red Sea splits open,
saves his people from Israel, from from Egypt.
No, we need a king. We can see
Now listen, all the other nations around us have a king.
We need one too.
But listen, isn't that the same reason that we
so quickly trust in other things besides God too?
We forget what God has done, but then we look around
and we see that man, their life seems so good
I it that seems to be working for them.
So maybe I need that too. May.
Maybe I am missing out on something here.
And instead of trusting the invisible
yet powerful God who works on his timing, not ours.
What we start doing is we start drifting away
to all these other weak kings,
trusting them to fix it.
Somehow
we see God as our safety net, not as our full trust.
See, you and I can be climbing the rock face of our lives.
We're sure glad that God is there if we'd ever need him,
but we don't really fully trust to where we're leaning back
and just falling knowing He's got it.
What is that? It's pride.
It's a rejection of God as king over us.
And so where's the hope in this chapter?
'cause it just kind of ends
Samuel's frustrated it seems like.
Get outta here. I don't even wanna see you anymore, right?
Where's the hope here? We know Israel's going
to get a king soon, but
but how do we understand this chapter?
'cause this is really the crux of the whole thing.
Well, here's what we need.
We, we need to go back a little bit
to help us understand this.
We need to go back in our minds to the book of Deuteronomy
where just a few hundred years earlier,
God had told the people through Moses
how this whole thing was gonna go Listen to this.
This is before they even entered the land.
It's kind of in the process of them coming into the land.
There's all of that. But they definitely were not settled.
This was not home yet.
But listen to what God says to the people.
This is Deuteronomy 17.
He says, when you come to the land
that the Lord your God is giving you and you possess it
and dwell in it and then say,
I'll set a king over me like all the nations that are
around me, you may indeed set a king over you whom the Lord
your God will choose one from among your brothers.
You shall set as king over you.
You may not put a foreigner over you who's
not your brother only.
He must not acquire many horses for himself
or cause the people to return
to Egypt, to acquire many horses.
Since the Lord has said to you,
you shall never return that way again.
He shall not acquire many wives for himself,
lest his heart turn away,
nor shall he acquire for himself excessive silver and gold.
And when he sits on the throne of his kingdom,
he shall write for himself in a book, a copy of this law
approved by the Levitical priests, and it shall be with him.
He shall read in it all the days of his life
that he may learn to fear the Lord is God.
By keeping all the words of the law and these statutes
and doing them, that his heart may not be lifted up
among above his brothers.
That he may not turn aside from the commandment either
to the right or the left, so
that he may continue long in his kingdom, he
and his children in Israel.
So notice what God did hundreds of years
before Sam for Samuel eight.
He said, Hey guys, this thing could work it.
It actually could work this way,
even with a king.
It could work. But did you see the conditions?
And and I want you to see this
because this has to be in our minds as we go forward
through one Samuel, as we go through second Samuel, as we go
through the rest of the Old Testament, this has
to be right on the forefront
of our minds thinking about the king.
He says, the king must be chosen by the Lord, not by people.
The king must be native to Israel, not a foreigner.
The king can't trust his wealth or his resources.
The king cannot have many wives
that would turn his heart away toward the lust of the flesh.
But there was also this, the last caveat.
He said they have to keep God's word
and the priesthood right in front of their face so
that they would obey God in holiness and humility.
It's the only way this was gonna work.
And notice the result. Did you see that?
So that he may continue long in his kingdom, he
and his children in Israel.
Again, this thing could work guys, in spite
of the people asking wrongly, in spite
of their rebellion against God, the Lord set it up
to work in this way in spite of themselves.
God would continue to work
to bring about his redemptive purposes in Israel
through a righteous king.
And we'll see it some in Saul. We'll see it a lot.
And David will see it a little bit throughout the rest
of the history of Israel.
The problem was none of them, none
of those kings could live up to that standard perfectly.
Not one of them could fully fulfill the design God had
for a righteous king in Israel.
None of 'em, even
with the conditions God set
what the people were wanting would never satisfy them.
That's why in God's grace, he gives us what we need.
In God's grace, he gives us what we actually need.
What they needed and what we needed was a perfect king,
A chosen son of David, native Israelite,
who fully trusts in and fully obedient to his God.
And here's what that means. All
of these kings in Israel's history that we will see in one
and two Samuel that we'll see throughout the rest,
they were all but shadows of the true king that was
to come whose name is Jesus.
They were contrast to what he would come to do perfectly,
where he would come listen to serve, not to be served,
where he would come and die for those who disappointed him,
not attack those who disappointed him, where he would come
to give to others rather than take from others.
And listen, it's the same thing for every other king
that you and I pursue in our daily lives, those
that we choose to follow, those that promise happiness
but only end up taking from us.
This God is an all together different king.
He was faithful to Israel even when they were
not faithful to him.
And he is faithful to us. Even today. He is faithful.
And here's how he proved it through the cross
of Jesus Christ, the ultimate display of God's love
and God's faithfulness, the ultimate giving of
what we truly needed.
It's found there
only Listen church.
That's why. That's why we can lean back
off the rock face and say, God, you got this.
And we don't have to try to climb
and find our foothold and our handle.
We don't have to because God is the one holding us.
He's a good king. And so let's worship him.
He's worthy of it.
God, thank you that we can,
we can lean back the way you say it,
Jesus, Matthew 11 is we can rest John 15,
we can abide
knowing that you give us life abundantly.
So God, I pray that we would not have any conditions,
not have any exceptions on us just leaning back in life,
whether it's a sin issue,
whether it's a wrong focus in our lives,
whether it's a trust
and a hope that we have this thing that's a felt need
and we're looking for something to fulfill that God, all of
that, may we lean back in you
and just trust that you have us
as our good perfect king.
Giving and giving and giving to us.
Lord, it's gonna take some courage.
I know for some in this room, as we heard
before, as I've experienced in my life some courage to say,
okay, God, this one's yours, and open our hands.
Let you have it Because you do.
Nothing's too strong for you. You are the rock.
As as Hannah prayed in one Samuel two,
there is no rock like our God.
There is no other king like our king.
Lead us to you, God, not only to sing,
but also to live for your glory.
In Jesus' name.